welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing ketamine ketamine is a
fascinating compound and it's one that
nowadays is being used both clinically
for the treatment of depression and
suicidality and PTSD and it is also a
drug that is commonly abused that is
ketamine is often used recreationally
and it has a high potential for abuse so
today we are going to discuss both the
research on the clinical benefits of
ketamine as well as the risks of
ketamine we're going to discuss the
mechanisms of action by which ketamine
produces what are called dissociative
States I will Define for you what a
so-called k-hole is in scientific terms
I will talk about dosages of ketamine
I'll talk about delivery routes of
ketamine and throughout I will be
emphasizing both the clinical benefits
and the risks that is the potential
harms of using ketamine out of the
appropriate clinical context so by the
end of today's episode you will
understand thoroughly what ketamine is
how it works in the brain and body to
produce dissociative States and to
relieve depression and you will
understand how it can actually change
neural circuitry this is an important
thing to understand about ketamine the
acute or immediate effects of ketamine
while one is under the influence of
ketamine are just part of the story of
how ketamine modifies the brain for the
treatment of depression suicidality and
PTSD and by extension when people use
ketamine recreationally there are those
immediate acute effects of ketamine but
there are also long-term changes in the
brain that are important to understand
during today's discussion we will also
be talking a lot about neuroplasticity
or your nervous system's ability to
change in response to experience and we
will be talking about neuroplasticity
not just in the context of ketamine but
as a general theme for how your nervous
system changes anytime you learn
anything and in that discussion you're
going to hear a lot about bdnf or brain
derived nootrophic Factor brain derived
nootrophic factor is a critical molecule
for all forms of learning and memory and
changes to your nervous system so in
addition to learning about ketamine and
how it works clinically and its
relevance to recreational use and abuse
you will also learn a lot about
neuroplasticity and bdnf and what it's
doing in your brain right now as you
learn before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Roca Roca
makes eyeglasses and sunglasses that are
of the absolute highest quality the
company was founded by two All-American
swimmers from Stanford and everything
about Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed with performance in mind
I've spent a lifetime working on the
biology of the visual system and I can
tell you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
different challenges in order for you to
be able to see clearly when for instance
you go from a shady area to a sunny area
when you look at something up close or
off in the distance
Roca understands all of that and have
designed their eyeglasses and sunglasses
so that regardless of conditions you
always see with perfect clarity their
glasses are also extremely lightweight
and they won't slip off your face if you
get sweaty in fact initially Roca
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
for use in sports things like running
and cycling Etc and they still can be
used for that but really their
eyeglasses and sunglasses are designed
to be worn anytime I wear readers at
night or when I drive at night and I'll
sometimes wear sunglasses in the middle
of the day although of course I do not
wear sunglasses when I do my morning
sunlight exposure which everyone should
be doing to set their circadian rhythm
if you'd like to try Roca eyeglasses or
sunglasses simply go to Roka that's
roka.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20 off your first order again
that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's episode is
also brought To Us by eight sleep eight
sleep makes Smart mattress covers with
cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity now I've spoken many times
before on this podcast and elsewhere
about the fact that sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance when we're
sleeping well and enough all of those
things are improved and when we are not
sleeping well or enough all of those
things mental health physical health and
performance all get worse now a key
component to getting a great night's
sleep is that the temperature of your
sleeping environment has to be such that
your body temperature drops by one to
three degrees in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep and that your body
temperature increase by about one to
three degrees in order to wake up
feeling refreshed with eight sleep
mattress covers you can customize the
temperature of your sleeping environment
such that you always get the best
possible night's sleep I've been
sleeping on a night sleep mattress cover
for about two years now and I must say
it has vastly improved my sleep if you'd
like to try eight sleep you can go to
adesleep.com huberman and save 150 off
off their pod 3 cover they currently
ship in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's eightsleep.com huberman okay
let's talk about ketamine I realize that
many people have heard of ketamine but
most people don't realize that ketamine
is very similar to another drug called
PCP or phen cycladine which goes by the
street names angel dust or Sherm it has
some other street names as well when I
was growing up I heard a lot about PCP
they taught us about it in school you'd
hear about it on you know cop shows on
television and the lore was that PCP
would eliminate people's perception of
pain and would make them violent you
know you'd hear these stories in drug
education classes that when people are
on PCP they're punching light poles and
breaking their hands you know they can
fight off eight or ten police officers
who are trying to handcuff them I don't
know whether or not any of that is true
or not but we heard a lot about PCP and
it was associated with drugs of abuse
things like cocaine methamphetamine it
was lumped into that category nowadays
when we hear about ketamine rarely do
people mention that ketamine and PCP
actually have the same mode of action
more or less okay I'm not talking about
the specifics I'm talking broadly they
have the same mode of action in the
brain that both of them are dissociative
anesthetics and nowadays usually when we
hear about ketamine we are hearing about
its benefits we are hearing that it can
help cure depression we are hearing that
it can help reduce or cure suicide
reality that it can be used to treat
PTSD and indeed all of that is true in
the appropriate clinical context at the
appropriate dosages and given that the
appropriate frequency ketamine has
proven to be a miraculous drug for some
people not all people for the treatment
of depression suicidality and PTSD
that said ketamine also has a very high
potential for abuse and so it may come
as no surprise that we often hear about
ketamine nowadays also in the context of
its use at parties you hear about people
going into so-called k-holes which is a
particular State associated with
overdoing the dosage of ketamine a
little or a lot we'll get back to that a
little bit later what it is how
dangerous it is ETC
in any case ketamine is an incredible
drug very similar to PCP phencyclidine
and it is a drug that nowadays there is
crossover between the clinical uses of
ketamine for treatment of depression Etc
and it's recreational use what do I mean
by that what I'm referring to is people
accessing ketamine legally for the
purpose of treating depression but
taking that ketamine out of the clinic
out of the doctor's office which is a
very different set of conditions than
most of the studies that have been done
on ketamine and its role in depression
and not surprisingly if there is
increased access to a drug like ketamine
really any drug that has a potential for
abuse then we also see an increase in
the number of people that are using that
drug recreationally and some of them do
indeed get addicted to ketamine so I
know many of you are probably wondering
can you get addicted to ketamine indeed
people can get addicted to ketamine
there are some people who like its
effects enough that they find themselves
compelled to use ketamine even though
the use of ketamine is degrading their
overall life performance so work school
relationships finances Etc
that said ketamine does have these
established clinical uses so nowadays
the landscape around ketamine is oh so
different than it was 10 or 20 years ago
when it was lumped very closely with PCP
phencyclidine and really just looked at
as a drug of abuse there were some early
cases in the 1970s of the use of
ketamine in order to treat PTSD this was
mainly in soldiers in Vietnam or people
coming back from Vietnam but really the
clinical use of ketamine for the
treatment of depression suicidality and
PTSD has really just taken off in the
last five to ten years and that's what's
brought us to this new landscape of
interest and understanding and use of
ketamine in the clinical and
recreational context so how is it that a
drug that at one time was really just
viewed as a street drug that was bad bad
bad is now being prescribed widely and
has all this interest surrounding it and
really this has to do with our
understanding of what depression is and
what depression isn't so I'd like to
just take one or two minutes and explain
to you a little bit about the history of
depression and its treatment what we
observe starting about the middle of the
last century so around 1950 but really
taking off in the early 1980s and 90s is
the so-called monoamine hypothesis of
depression monoamines as the name
suggests are synthesized from amino
acids that's a good way to remember
monoamines monoamines include things
like serotonin dopamine and
norepinephrine although there are other
monoamines as well
monoamines are neurotransmitters or more
specifically they are neuromodulators
meaning they change the activity of
neural circuits in the brain and body
they can ramp up levels of activity in
lots of different brain areas where they
can reduce the activity of neural
circuits in lots of different brain
areas as well as within the body right
your gut has serotonin and needs
serotonin dopamine also plays important
roles in the body
etc etc the monoamine hypothesis of
depression is really centered around the
idea that it is deficiencies in these
monoamines either serotonin or dopamine
or norepinephrine or some combination of
those that gives rise to depression now
in reality there is very little if any
evidence that there is a deficiency of
monoamines in any form of depression
however it is very clear that drugs that
increase certain monoamines so drugs
like Prozac or Zoloft that increase
serotonin or drugs like bupren which is
often called Wellbutrin which is its
commercial name which increases dopamine
and norepinephrine can often provide
relief for certain symptoms of
depression in some people however what
we've learned over the last 30 or 40
years is that drugs that are designed to
increase certain monoamines in order to
treat depression only work in about 40
percent of depressed people that take
them and they have a lot of side effects
now some people are lucky enough that
they can use a low enough dose or
perhaps even a high enough dose that
gives them relief from their depressive
symptoms but does not give them side
effects that make it so uncomfortable
for them to use that drug that they
would choose rather to not take that
drug however a lot of people that do get
depression relief from things like
Zoloft or Paxil or from buprone find
that the side effects which include
things like dry mouth although more
commonly reductions or increases in
appetite or vast reductions in libido or
changes in their sleep patterns Etc that
those side effects really make it
impossible or at least very
uncomfortable for them to take those
drugs and of course there are the 60
percent of depressed people who do not
respond to those drugs at all now I want
to be very clear things like ssris
things like Wellbutrin have helped a
tremendous number of people get relief
from depressive symptoms and in many
cases have warded off suicidality as
well however there are also a great
number of people who have experienced a
lot of side effects and problems from
these drugs hence the desire to find
other compounds that can treat
depression without creating similar side
effect profiles and that ideally can
provide relief not just for 40 percent
but for all people suffering from
depression so that's where ketamine
enters the picture prior to the 1990s
they were mainly studied in neuroscience
and pharmacology Laboratories for their
abuse properties and for their
anesthetic properties so ketamine is a
dissociative anesthetic it's actually
used to induce certain forms of
anesthesia for surgery it's not always
used but it's often used this is
something that if you've ever had a
surgery you might want to ask your
anesthesiologist about you know what
sorts of drugs are you giving me to go
under what sorts of drugs are you
keeping me to stay under and maybe even
what sorts of drugs are you giving me to
bring me out of anesthesia because it
turns out that when you go into
anesthesia your anesthesiologist is
rarely giving you just one drug
typically they're giving you one drug to
you know kill off a little bit of
anxiety and maybe eliminate a little bit
of pain sometimes and then they'll give
you another drug to drop you into a
deeper plane of anesthesia and then
nowadays there are sophisticated ways to
monitor your plane of anesthesia and
their sophisticated ways to if necessary
get you out of a deep plane of
anesthesia if that plane of anesthesia
is too deep when I talk about a plane of
anesthesia I'm just talking about going
from Full wakefulness to you know a
reduction in anxiety to falling asleep
to a sleep to the point where even if
someone were to pinch your toe or your
arm like a really intense pinch that you
wouldn't wake up from that okay so
ketamine has the property of being an
anesthetic it kills the response to pain
and at certain doses it can bring you
into deep planes of anesthesia at lesser
dosages it can take you into transition
points between awake and deeply
anesthetized and it's really that
transition point between awake and
deeply anesthetize which we are going to
call the dissociative State it's kind of
this liminal State a little bit like
dreaming it can have some dreamlike
qualities to it that's the state that
has most often been sought after or
employed for the treatment of depression
suicidality and PTSD which brings up a
really important point which is that
when people use ketamine recreationally
it's not clear exactly what plane of
anesthesia or dissociation they are
actually seeking and this is why we hear
about some of the desired effects of
ketamine that are driving people to use
it recreationally and while we also hear
about people having some unpleasant or
even very unpleasant or dangerous
experiences when using ketamine
recreationally because we're talking
about a drug that has a lot of different
effects depending on the dosages and as
we'll soon talk about individuals vary
tremendously in their response to
different dosages of ketamine and the
delivery route for ketamine whether or
not it's delivered orally in the form of
a pill or put sublingually in what's
called atroche that dissolves under the
tongue or it's injected and then it's
injected into the vein or
intramuscularly Etc each of those can
produce very different effects in terms
of this speed of onset of the drug and
the type of effects that it produces in
the brain and body so what happened in
the early 90s is that Laboratories that
were studying animal models what we call
pre-clinical models of things like
depression and learning and memory and
to some extent ketamine but mainly
focusing on learning and memory and
depression made an interesting Discovery
there's a certain pre-clinical model of
depression that's pretty common in
Laboratories that involves taking a rat
or a mouse and putting it into a small
container like it looks like a beaker or
a jar sometimes it's a tray and it has
water in it and you might be surprised
to learn perhaps not that if you put a
rat or a mouse into water it will swim
okay so it's treading water in order to
keep its head above water and not drown
I realize for some of you this might be
a bit of an aversive topic to hear about
animal research but this is one of the
common preclinical models of depression
which is put a rat or a mouse into water
let it swim and see at what point it
gives up because what happens is if you
put a rat or Mouse into water it will
attempt to save its own life by swimming
but at some point it will just give up
and it will just start sinking and then
of course the researcher needs to rescue
the router Mouse put it back into its
home cage dry it off give it some food
Etc this preclinical model is called the
model of learn helplessness and it's
become a prominent pre-clinical model of
depression because of course we can't
ask mice or rats if they are depressed
or happy I suppose you can ask them but
they're not going to answer in any kind
of meaningful way so we can only look at
their behavior in order to understand
whether or not they have a sense of
happiness or a sense of depression and
of course that's very hard to gauge in
an animal model of any kind you could
make guesses based on other behaviors
like are they grooming regularly are
they eating regularly you know things
that more or less parallel what we think
of as health or lack of Health in a
human who's happy or depressed but in
the context of trying to understand
depression in these pre-clinical animal
models having a behavior that you can
really quantify carefully across a lot
of different animals and conditions is
really beneficial so this thing of
putting a rat or Mouse into water and
seeing how long it takes before they
give up to save their own life is called
the model of learned helplessness and
what it allowed researchers to do was to
take routes and mice put them into water
see how long it took before they gave up
and then to give them different drugs to
see whether or not any of those drugs
either hastened sped up or prolonged the
duration over which the animal would
attempt to save its own life this
actually has some meaningful parallels
to human depression you know one of the
Hallmarks of depression is that people
stop thinking positively about their
future depression of course can include
a lot of other symptoms you know one of
the most prominent symptoms of
depression for instance is consistently
waking up around 2 30 or 3 30 in the
morning and not being able to fall back
asleep again now keep in mind
it is not the case that if you're waking
up at 2 30 or 3 30 in the morning and
you can't fall back asleep that you are
absolutely depressed that's simply not
the case
but that pattern of lack of sleep plus
some other things like lack of
anticipation of a positive future
inability to imagine the future in any
kind of meaningful or positive way
Etc are part of the key features of what
we call a major depressive episode so
this pre-clinical model of learned
helplessness allowed researchers to test
a lot of different drugs and establish
which drugs at which dosages allowed
animals to fight for their life longer
when placed into water it's really that
simple as a model but it revealed some
very interesting things at least one of
which is that when animals were injected
with ketamine this dissociative
anesthetic but they were injected with
dosages of ketamine that were below what
would induce full anesthesia these
animals would swim for their life for a
lot longer now to some extent that ought
to be surprising and in fact was
surprising to researchers because
ketamine is what's called an nmda
receptor blocker now when I say blocker
I'm not getting into the details of what
specific form of blocker it is but I do
want to mention that a blocker is
sometimes referred to as an antagonist
whereas something that promotes the
activity of a receptor is called an
Agonist okay so if you can just remember
that ketamine is an nmda receptor
antagonist or blocker then you should be
fine for the rest of today's
conversation now I haven't told you what
nmda is nmda stands for n-methyl-d
aspartate and you do not need to
remember that but the surprise for
researchers was that this drug ketamine
is allowing animals to fight for their
life for longer so it has this sort of
property of overcoming what we call
learned helplessness or a sense of
helplessness AKA antidepressant effects
and we also know that it's an nmda
receptor antagonist or blocker and
that's perplexing because we also know
that the nmda receptor is critical for
changing neural circuitry in the brain
it's critical for neuroplasticity so put
differently here's a drug that blocks
the receptor that's critical for
neuroplasticity for changes in the brain
and yet somehow it's allowing these
animals to fight for their life longer
it's somehow giving them more of a sense
of hope at least that's the subjective
interpretation of what one observes when
a mouse or rat is swimming for much
longer when it would otherwise just give
up and sink to the bottom of the vessel
now in general there are two kinds of
scientists there are scientists that
take a look at a set of findings like
that and say oh here's a drug that's
supposed to be terrible for us it's an
anesthetic and it blocks nmda receptors
and nmda receptors are good for
neuroplasticity and somehow it's also
allowing these animals to swim longer
and I would say one category of
scientists would just look at that and
just say wow that is a big ball or
tangle of confused facts like how does
one even reconcile that right brain
change ought to be good and perhaps even
lie at the heart of our ability to
recover from depression this is drug
that blocks neuroplasticity but somehow
is relieving depression I'm going to
walk away from that I'm going to work on
something far simpler and then there's
this other category of scientists which
thank goodness exists who looks at that
apparent contradiction of okay there's a
drug which blocks plasticity plasticity
is thought to be important for getting
over depression and yet the drug can
provide some relief from depression at
least in these preclinical animal models
and they say hmm I like a good puzzle
right the more complex the puzzle the
more interesting and they start digging
in with pre-clinical studies and they
start talking to clinicians who are
treating patients for depression and
like I said thank goodness these sorts
of scientists exist and thank goodness
they did that because it turned out that
when clinicians tried ketamine in
depressed patients as a means to relieve
depression it had remarkable effects so
it was about the year 2000 when the
first sets of papers about the clinical
use of ketamine for the treatment of
Depression started to emerge now we have
to remember the context in which all of
this was happening you know in 2000
drugs like Prozac and some of similar
ssris selective serotonin reuptake
Inhibitors things like Wellbutrin were
really hitting the market in full force
and as we talked about earlier some
people were getting relief some people
were getting relief with a lot of side
effects and therefore deciding not to
take those drugs and a lot of people the
majority of people that were taking
those drugs were not getting relief so
there was a real urgent need to find
other drugs for the treatment of
depression and ketamine at least based
on its apparent profile of being a
dissociative anesthetic would seem like
the last drug that you'd want to use to
treat depression right it dissociates
people even hear about dissociation as a
symptom of depression and yet what
happened was a small number very
pioneering clinicians started to explore
the use of ketamine in the clinic for
the treatment of depression and in
particular for depression that did not
respond to any other treatment so there
was a real critical need to find other
compounds and a bit more motivation to
test some of these let's call them
atypical compounds for the treatment of
depression so one of the first Landmark
papers in the use of ketamine for the
treatment of depression is entitled
antidepressant effects of ketamine in
depressed patients this is a paper that
I've provided a link to in the show note
captions it's a small study okay so it
doesn't involve many subjects at all it
really just has seven subjects all of
whom had major depression and they did
intravenous injections with half a
milligram per kilogram of body weight of
ketamine now that dosage half a
milligram per kilogram of body weight
turns out to be very important for
today's discussion because it's going to
serve as a reference point for later
discussions when we get into other modes
of delivery of ketamine such as oral
pill form ketamine or sublingual
ketamine and as it relates to things
like the k-hole or the dissociative
State or the various effects that
ketamine can have depending on the
dosage and the delivery route meanwhile
going back to this study what they found
is that when they injected patients with
severe depression with ketamine the
effects of ketamine took place within
minutes within 10 or 15 minutes and that
they experienced a sort of peak euphoric
State okay so they're not inducing deep
anesthesia right at this dosage they're
getting people into a kind of euphoric
dreamy semi-dissociative state that
occurred within 15 minutes and really
peaked about 45 minutes to an hour after
they were injected with the drug and
that the total effects of the drug in
terms of euphoria
were effectively over by about two hours
or so and that time course of effects
makes perfect sense if you look at say
the half-life of ketamine which is how
long it takes for half of the drug to be
active in the system Etc but what was
really interesting about this study and
others like it is that the patients
experienced relief from their depression
almost immediately after taking the drug
So within minutes to hours and that it
persisted for several days after taking
the ketamine okay so the dissociative
euphoric dreamlike effects of ketamine
take place very quickly they're very
very Salient right the person basically
is just lying there experiencing this
euphoric dreamliked associative state
and they get some relief from their
depression immediately and yet there's
persistent relief from that depression
which lasted at least three days out
from the treatment
now a key theme of today's discussion is
going to be that the antidepressant
effects of ketamine appear to be fairly
short-lived at least when one is
exploring one or two treatments with
ketamine in other words the typical
Contour is that people will take
ketamine get this euphoric dreamlike
dissociative effect come out of that
feeling some immediate relief from their
depression this is one of the things
that makes ketamine an incredibly
attractive drug for the treatment of
depression especially depression that
hasn't responded to other forms of
treatment which is that people get
relief very very quickly indeed the same
day that they initiate the treatment
now this is especially important when
you think about the fact that the
monoamine hypothesis of depression which
drove the discovery and development of
all these drugs like ssris Wellbutrin
etc those drugs often can provide
support for people with depression again
only 40 of people get true relief from
their depression and again there are
some side effect issues or major side
effect issues in some cases that have to
be dealt with but even the positive
effects even under the best conditions
oftentimes those effects don't kick in
for weeks or months after somebody
initiates taking the drug now that might
not seem like a long time to wait for
some of you but if you are somebody
suffering from depression even another
day even another hour with depression
seems almost unmanageable and sadly many
people who have these forms of
depression will go on to commit suicide
so it is ever so important that there be
rapid treatments for depression even
same day treatments for depression and
based on the study it appeared that
ketamine was and indeed Still Remains
that drug
now I certainly don't want to position
ketamine in your mind as a miracle drug
for depression in fact I don't actually
believe in Miracle drugs I don't think
that there is any compound that alone
can produce all the desired effects that
one wants without any negative effects
in a way that could warrant calling it a
miracle drug that's just not how biology
works there's always an interplay
between pharmacology between our
behaviors and what we choose to do or
not do this is a topic we'll get into a
little bit later when we talk about
anti-depressive behaviors and the role
of ketamine in bringing about
anti-depressive behaviors for the relief
of depression now with that said the
study that I just mentioned as well as
many many other studies that followed
emphasize that ketamine could provide
significant decreases in not just
depression and suicidality but also the
feelings of helplessness and
worthlessness that are associated with
major depression and again it could do
that in people that also were not
responding to other forms of depression
treatment such as ssris
Etc
so while we don't want to call it a
miracle drug ketamine turned out to be
and remains an incredible drug for the
treatment of depression in certain cases
now in addition to that ketamine has
been shown in clinical studies to
provide relief not just for treatment
resistant depression of the major
depression type right there's many
different forms of depression but major
depression is the one that we're
normally thinking about or referring to
when we talk about depression but
ketamine has also been shown to be
effective in treating bipolar depression
sometimes called bipolar disorder
although more commonly nowadays called
bipolar depression I did an entire
episode by the way on bipolar depression
if you want to know what it is and what
it isn't how it differs from borderline
personality disorder Etc you can go to
hubermanlab.com just put into the search
function bipolar and it will take you to
that episode ketamine has also been
shown to be useful for the treatment of
PTSD and for OCD obsessive-compulsive
disorder and for anxiety and for various
forms of substance addiction so ketamine
is not a miracle drug but it does seem
to have broad application and to be very
successful for the treatment of a lot of
major psychiatric challenges now just
because ketamine has shown these
incredible applications it also has some
serious problems that are directly
related to how it works in the brain or
at least from what we understand of how
it works in the brain what I'm referring
to here is yes ketamine is very rapid
acting it can often provide relief from
depression almost immediately meaning
same day
however it is very short-lived after
about three days or a week or so the
antidepressant effects of ketamine often
wear off
so that creates a situation where people
perhaps need to take ketamine every week
and yet it creates enough of a
dissociative State meaning it takes
people enough out of their normal daily
routine that the prospect of people
taking ketamine every week is actually
not that feasible and also because of
some of the propensity for ketamine to
become a drug of abuse that is for it to
be habit-forming and or addicting
one also worries that if people are
doing ketamine every week to treat their
depression that they can become
so-called hooked on ketamine now
fortunately there have been studies of
ketamine and how it works not just in
the short term but in the longer term
that have led to some very important
clinical studies that have explored for
instance people taking ketamine twice
per week for a duration of three weeks
total
and what they find is that yes after the
first time they take it they get some
relief from depression they take it a
second time that week they get some
relief from depression and they do the
same thing the next week and the next
week and when they do that they get
relief from depression the whole way
through that entire three weeks
but it turns out that there's also some
so-called durability to the effect such
that if people do this twice a week
dosing regimen so ketamine twice a week
for three weeks total they find that
when they end that three weeks they get
some ongoing relief from their
depressive symptoms which can extend
months or more before they have to
repeat that twice a week for three weeks
regimen now certainly not all studies of
using ketamine for the treatment of
depression have used that exact dosage
regimen twice a week for three weeks
then take some time off repeat twice a
week for three weeks take some time off
repeat some have explored giving
ketamine once per week or even three
times per week or doing it once a week
for five weeks and then taking an
extended period of time off before
repeating the treatment schedule there
are a bunch of different studies out
there but when one looks at all of those
studies and mass together it's very
clear that ketamine is providing relief
from depressive symptoms immediately and
in the days after the treatment but that
when those treatments are act fairly
closely together that there is some
durability some ongoing relief from
depression and what this tells us is
very important in fact I hope everybody
really highlight this in their minds as
they're hearing it it's very likely that
ketamine is acting by at least two and
probably three different mechanisms in
order to provide relief from depression
one of those mechanisms induces relief
from depression very quickly and seems
to be associated with that euphoric
dissociative dreamlike state that one
experiences when they are under the
influence of ketamine the second
mechanism seems to provide relief from
depression in the days and weeks that
follow the ketamine treatment and there
also appears to be a third mechanism by
which ketamine can induce long lasting
changes in the nervous system and it is
those three mechanisms short medium and
long-term mechanisms that produce the
kinds of changes in neurochemistry and
more importantly changes in actual
neural circuit wiring that allows
ketamine to provide this incredible
relief from depression so next we're
going to turn to what those mechanisms
are because in understanding those
mechanisms you will understand how
ketamine provides this relief from
depression but you'll also come to
understand the more important broader
theme of what depression is really all
about at a neural circuit level and how
relief from depression is all about
neuroplasticity
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but oftentimes I simply
can't get enough servings but with ag1
I'm sure to get enough vitamins and
minerals and the probiotics that I need
and it also contains adaptogens to help
buffer stress simply put I always feel
better when I take ag1 I have more focus
and energy and I sleep better and it
also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com huberman
to claim a special offer from now until
August 12 2023 ag1 is giving away 10
free travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again if you go to
drinkag1.com huberman you can claim the
special offer of 10 free travel packs
plus a year supply of vitamin D3 K2 so
how is ketamine really working we
already established that ketamine blocks
the nmda receptor and that the nmda
receptor is critical for many forms not
all but many forms of neuroplasticity
now I realize some of you might be
familiar with so-called ligands and
receptors but most of you probably are
not a ligand is a chemical that binds to
a receptor and a receptor is like a
little parking spot on the outside of a
cell there can also be receptors inside
of cells but most of the time when we're
talking about nerve cells neurons and
you hear the word receptors you're
hearing about receptors on the outside
of the cell
so the nmda receptor does not exist in
our neurons in order to bind ketamine
it's there actually to bind all sorts of
other things that are endogenous that
are naturally made by us but ketamine
has a very high what's called Affinity
it has a very high probability of
binding to the nmda receptor if it's
introduced to our bloodstream so when
ketamine is taken in pill form
sublingual form meaning under the tongue
when it's injected into the muscle or
the vein it gets into the bloodstream
and then it's able to cross easily
across the blood-brain barrier the
so-called BBB blood-brain barrier the
blood-brain barrier keeps a lot of
things out of the brain but ketamine can
very readily pass across the blood-brain
barrier once it's in the brain it has a
very high affinity for meaning it knows
how to seek out and bind to those nmda
receptors now the simplest way to
explain how nmda receptors ordinarily
contribute to neuroplasticity is that
they represent what's called an and gate
and an and gate as the name suggests is
a function in a cell or in a system
where two things have to be present in
fact for those of you that have a bit of
an engineering or computer programming
background you'll be familiar with and
gates for those of you that don't don't
worry about it I'm going to explain what
an and gate is right now an and gate in
the context of nervous system function
is when two things are present like
chemical a and chemical B both have to
be present in order for some process say
neuroplasticity to occur the nmda
receptor as I mentioned earlier is a
receptor on the surface of neurons and
it binds glutamate which is a molecule
that we all make in our brain and it
activates other neurons it's what's
called an excitatory neurotransmitter
now there are lots of different
receptors for glutamate and those
receptors are binding glutamate all the
time however in order to activate the
nmda receptor there has to be a lot of
glutamate present and it has to happen
over a very brief period of time so the
nmda receptor is an and gate in the
sense that glutamate has to be present
and to bind it and it has to get a lot
of electrical activity a lot of input in
order for that to happen so it's a
receptor that responds primarily to
unusually high or frequent levels of
electrical activity let's place this in
real world context so that it makes a
bit more sense I like most all of you
and moving my arms around a lot
throughout the day now as an adult my
motor cortex the area of my brain that
controls motor coordination of my limbs
has connections from my brain to my
spinal cord from my spinal cord to my
muscles and that's what allows me to
move my limbs
under conditions of just moving my limbs
and doing things throughout the day
drinking a cup of coffee or yerba mate
you know walking outside to view some
sunlight in the morning doing the things
that I do every single day and that I
already know how to do
glutamate is definitely involved in that
process glutamate binding to its other
receptor types which are called ampa
receptors for those of you that want to
know that's involved in that process
it's typical levels of activity
if however I were to sit down at this
desk and be commanded to or decide to do
some specific motor limb movement let's
say move my hand in a three dot sequence
for those of you watching you can see
this for those of you that are listening
don't worry about it it's not very
interesting to watch the point is just
that I'm going to put my finger down in
one two three points on the desk in
front of me and then three two one point
coming back to me now that's obviously a
motor sequence that I can perform I just
did it so clearly I can perform it but
if I were to do that for let's say an
hour
what would happen is the neurons that
are involved in generating that motor
sequence of one two three three two one
one two three three two one would be
active over and over and over again and
what would likely happen because of that
unusual frankly motor behavior is that
the neurons responsible for generating
that motor Behavior would be able to
detect it as unusually frequent
unusually high levels of activity in the
circuits that generate that behavior and
the increase in glutamate that's
impinging on the neurons in that circuit
would bind the nmda receptor making it
change several important things the
first of which is that your nervous
system is capable of changing but that's
an energetically demanding process so
the incredible thing about
neuroplasticity is that when you
generate an unusually high or just an
unusual pattern of activity motor
activity or you're hearing a new
language you're trying to learn that or
you're navigating a new city the neurons
are firing in ways that are atypical for
them and they are firing a lot more and
so the neurons are going to bind
glutamate they the nmda receptor is
going to be activated and then
Downstream of nmda receptor activation
are a bunch of what we call
intracellular processes a bunch of
things that happen in the cells to try
and make that behavior occur again and
again if needed but without the huge
energetic demand you've experienced this
before when you're trying to learn
something and it feels sluggish it feels
hard it's frustrating and then
eventually you learn it and it's very
facile it's very easy
one of the reasons for that is that when
the nmda receptor is activated by these
infrequent or unusual patterns of
activity it can then recruit other
glutamate receptors the more typical
kind the ampa type receptors to the cell
surface and then those receptors can
simply bind the glutamate and allow that
behavior to occur without this whole
process that's involved in
neuroplasticity having to engage and do
things like build new proteins in the
cell build new Machinery Etc so to just
step back from this the way to think
about the nmda receptor is that
activation of the nmda receptor only
occurs under conditions of unusually
high or simply unusual patterns of
activity that the nmda receptor yes
controls neural activity in the
immediate sense like when it's activated
it's changing the patterns of activity
in the neuron sure but it also can
engage gene expression and introduce new
receptors to the cell basically giving
the cell the ability to then recreate
the same patterns of activity without
having to do it in such a metabolically
demanding way in fact a good analogy for
all of this is the way that muscles can
hypertrophy right if you overload
muscles properly through resistance
training of any kind and then give them
a period of rest there's recruitment of
specific things to the muscle fibers as
well as recruitment of changes in the
nerves that innervate that control the
contraction of those muscles and then
those muscles grow they get stronger Etc
and they are able to function and use
that new strength and new growth and you
don't have to damage those muscle fibers
or trigger those adaptations over and
over again to maintain them because you
have this new capability now I realize
that's a lot of details about nmda
receptors and neuroplasticity but really
if we needed to pick one biological
mechanism that resides at the center of
many many important forms of
neuroplasticity it would be the nmda
receptor and its functions that I just
told you about so now that you have that
in mind that these nmda receptors are
critical at detecting unusual activity
making changes to cells so the cells can
then respect respond to that activity in
the future you have in mind the
conceptual basis for understanding how
ketamine works because as I've mentioned
several times already ketamine is an
nmda receptor blocker antagonist and yet
we know that a lot of the changes in the
brain that underlie the transition from
a depressed state to a non-depressed
state involve neuroplasticity so what's
going on there well what's going on
there turns out to be extremely
interesting and you can understand it
very easily if you understand that there
are essentially two major types of
neurons in the brain you have those
excitatory neurons meaning neurons that
when they are activated electrically
they activate or excite other neurons at
least they try to they release
neurotransmitter into the synapse which
is the little gap between neurons the
neurons on the other side have receptors
they bind those neurotransmitters in
this case glutamate which is the major
excitatory neurotransmitter in the brain
and then there's a high probability that
those other neurons will be excited that
they will be electrically active that's
one major type of so-called
neurotransmission in the brain the other
major type of neurotransmission in the
brain is called inhibitory
neurotransmission inhibitory
neurotransmission involves neurons that
release the neurotransmitter Gaba or
sometimes also another molecule called
glycine but mostly Gaba when Gaba is
released it has the property of reducing
the probability that the next neuron
will be electrically active in fact
gaba's job is to bind to receptors on
the next cell and to make it less
electrically active so we've got
excitatory neurotransmission and we have
inhibitory neurotransmission and just to
place inhibitory and excitatory
neurotransmission into context if you
think about a condition like epilepsy
which involves seizures of either the
smaller type called petit mal seizures
or grand mal seizures which are the type
in which people have body-wide
convulsions they are often disengaged
from whatever's going on around them in
those moments they're shaking quite a
lot Etc there are many causes of
seizures but to get to the heart of what
a seizure is it is essentially runaway
excitation in the brain a small region
of the brain becomes especially
electrically active and then it spreads
out from that Foci that focus of the
excitation and it recruits a lot of
neurons in a fairly non-specific way
creating these seizure-like motor
patterns in the body and patterns of
activity in the brain that can involve
disengagement from immediate experience
and lack of perception sometimes there's
Aura there's a whole discussion to be
had about seizure and by the way seizure
can occur in a lot of different contexts
of course it can occur in epilepsy it
can occur after a head injury
Etc we'll cover seizure in a future
episode of this podcast of course but
one of the major causes of seizure and
by extension lack of seizure is that
ordinarily inhibitory neurons and
excitatory neurons are in this kind of
push-pull that for somebody that doesn't
experience seizures puts the brain in
Balance so they don't have seizures
right the inhibitory neuron are
suppressing the activity of many neurons
so that those many neurons don't get
runaway excitation you don't get
seizures the excitatory neurons are
feeding back onto the inhibitory neurons
so everything is kept in Balance there
isn't too much inhibition there isn't
too much excitation everything's in
Balance okay so now you understand that
there are nmda receptors and these are
critical for many forms of
neuroplasticity you also understand that
there are excitatory neurons which
stimulate the electrical activity of
other neurons
and that there are inhibitory neurons in
your brain that inhibit or suppress the
activity of other neurons and that you
need excitatory and inhibitory
communication between neurons at all
times and that it has to remain in
balance and that the nmda receptor is
normally just sort of sitting there not
doing a whole lot unless levels of
neural activity are elevated above their
normal Baseline and then you can get
changes in the neural circuits and those
changes can be very long lasting and
let's not forget the piece of
information most pertinent to today's
discussion which is about ketamine which
is that ketamine blocks that nmda
receptor and there's the conundrum I
keep coming back to which is you need
neuroplasticity in order to get relief
from depression so what researchers have
discovered is that yes ketamine blocks
the nmda receptor it actually quiets
down neurons it prevents neurons from
being as active as they normally would
be and yet somehow almost paradoxically
it increases neuroplasticity in brain
circuits that are involved in mood and
reward in self-reflection we'll get into
what those brain circuits are in a
little bit
the way it works is that ketamine binds
to the nmda receptor present on
inhibitory neurons and in doing so
dramatically reduces the amount of
inhibition coming from those inhibitory
neurons onto excitatory neurons
when that happens the excitatory neurons
in specific circuits of the brain are
allowed to increase their activity they
do what's called bursting bursting is a
pattern of electrical activity whereby
normally one of these excitatory neurons
is releasing glutamate in a pattern that
might look or sound like this it
actually doesn't make a sound in the
brain but if you were to record from one
of these neurons which people have done
many times over and then you were to
convert the electrical signal in those
neurons to an audio monitor you would
hear the firing the action potential of
those neurons as a that's what it
actually sounds like on the Audio
Monitor it sounds like a little bit of
static
but if the normal firing of the neuron
is
which is the pretty typical Baseline
firing of the neurons in the relevant
circuits to mood that I'm going to be
discussing under conditions where
ketamine has been brought into the
system binds that nmda receptor
blocks the output of those inhibitory
neurons onto the excitatory neuron now
the excitatory neuron is firing in burst
and those bursting patterns of
electrical activity are the absolute
perfect patterns of activity that induce
not just short-term but long-term
changes in the neural circuits
associated with reward with dopamine
release with disappointment and with
mood in ways that are directly relevant
to suppressing or providing relief from
the symptoms of major depression now I
realized what I just told you is a lot
of information in fact what I just
described represents essentially what I
would teach to an advanced undergraduate
graduate course Medical School course on
neuroplasticity and how ketamine works
so keep in mind that we're having a
discussion here that is at a fairly high
level and if you could understand even a
tiny fraction even just one bit it what
I just described you're doing great if
you could understand more
outstanding
just to make sure that everyone's on the
same page as we move forward because I
do want to make sure that everyone
understands ketamine and how it works
because it does have these sort of
cryptic functions of engaging
neuroplasticity in ways that aren't
obvious if you just ask you know what
does ketamine do when you inject it what
does ketamine produce in terms of a
feeling State and then you know how does
somebody get relief from depression that
can all start to get a little bit
muddled unless you understand the
following so I'm going to tell it to you
again in just very top Contour terms
somebody takes a pill or an injection or
sublingual ketamine it makes its way
into the bloodstream and then it makes
its way into the brain once it's in the
brain it binds to a particular category
of receptors called the nmda receptor
the nmda receptor is a receptor that
normally is quiescent it's just kind of
sitting there it doesn't tend to do a
lot under normal conditions of everyday
life however the nmda receptors typical
function okay so when there's no
ketamine in the body or brain is to to
detect abnormal levels of neural
activity and in doing so recruit changes
to cells receptors Etc literally change
the neurons in ways that allow them to
respond to that activity in the future
without having to be under such big
metabolic demand and they do that by
recruiting more receptors Etc much in
the same way as when you overload a
muscle in the gym it will eventually
recover if you allow it to recover and
it will get stronger through the
addition of a bunch of new proteins the
nerve communication of that muscle will
change the muscle and the nerve to
muscle connection change it gets
stronger and sometimes it gets bigger
and stronger in the same way a neuron
can change the way it functions in
response to experience and neurons don't
know experience of life in any other way
except the patterns of electrical
activity and chemical activity that
impinges on them okay now ketamine the
drug binds to and blocks that nmda
receptor so the obvious conclusion would
be that ketamine prevents
neuroplasticity and that's not what
happens we know that ketamine actually
induces neuroplasticity and it does so
specifically in the brain circuits that
control mood
the net consequence being improvements
in mood how does that happen it happens
because ketamine binds to and blocks
those nmda receptors on inhibitory
neurons the inhibitory neurons are the
neurons that normally suppress the
activity of other neurons so when
ketamine binds to the nmda receptor
the activity of those inhibitory neurons
is reduced and as a consequence
excitatory communication between neurons
in those mood-related circuits increases
and it increases it in a way that
recruits neuroplasticity that
strengthens those connections and makes
them more likely to be active in the
future now it is not the case at least
at clinical doses the ketamine induces
seizures it certainly can at higher
doses but at clinical doses when
ketamine suppresses the activity of
those inhibitory neurons and the
excitatory neurons ramp up their
activity they're ramping up their
activity a lot and enough to create
changes in those neural circuits
associated with mood and the changes are
in the direction of making those neural
circuits more likely to generate
positive mood and less likely to
generate negative mood we'll get into
the specifics of those circuits in a
little bit
but ketamine is not creating the kind of
enormous increases in excitatory
communication between neurons that leads
to that runaway excitation now the point
of the discussion we just had over the
last 10 minutes or so was several fold
first of all I do believe it's important
to understand the key components of
neuroplasticity which is this remarkable
feature of our brain and nervous system
that we all have right this ability to
change our own brain circuits no other
organ in the body as far as we know can
direct its own changes but we can direct
our own brain changes and the nmda
receptor is absolutely critical for that
I also think it's important to
understand the difference between
inhibitory and excitatory communication
between neurons because that's just
Central to understanding brain function
brain function is a series of
accelerators and breaks it's not all
about neurons stimulating other neurons
it's also about neurons preventing the
activation of other neurons that's just
Central to everything not just
preventing seizures but it's Central to
learning it's Central to vision is
Central to hearing it's Central to
creativity it is at the core of brain
function and the other reason to have
the discussion we just did is that
ketamine has this incredible property it
can literally change the neural circuits
that generate mood that generate your
feelings of well-being but it does so
through a somewhat convoluted pathway
right it blocks the receptor that
everyone thinks is involved in
neuroplasticity and in doing so it
actually creates neuroplasticity now
even though I just described all of that
to you over the last 10 minutes or so
keep in mind that what I just described
to you as a process that actually occurs
in the brain takes many many days it
involves cells changing gene expression
making new proteins new receptors
anytime we say neuroplasticity even when
you read about so-called short-term
neuroplasticity it is happening over the
course of at least many many hours and
more likely many days or even weeks so
the process I just described of how
ketamine creates neuroplasticity through
blockade of nmda receptors is very
likely to be the process that explains
the longer term changes in mood and
affect that are associated with ketamine
therapy for the treatment of depression
now it is possible that ketamine
blocking the nmda receptor is also
responsible for some of the immediate
effects of ketamine that people
experience when they take the drug the
dissociation the in some cases euphoria
and that sort of dreamlike state that it
can put people into that is possible but
it's very clear that the nmda receptor
blockade is critical for the
neuroplastic changes that are going to
occur over the days and weeks following
ketamine treatment and if you think back
to our earlier discussion when we were
talking about the two time a week over
three week type regimen of taking
ketamine or some variant on that now it
might start to make sense as to why yes
there is immediate and short-term
benefit of taking ketamine for
depression in the clinically appropriate
setting of course I'm not talking about
recreational use right now but that also
there's some durability of those effects
that even after the three weeks of
taking ketamine twice per week people
often will experience weeks or months of
relief from depression when they're not
doing the weekly ketamine therapy
sessions so that longer term relief that
I'm referring to as durability of the
treatment is very likely to be the
consequence of actual neural circuit
reward wiring now there's an additional
and very important facet to this whole
discussion about neuroplasticity in
response to ketamine treatment for
depression if you recall that the burst
firing that induces that plasticity
I told you it induces plasticity but I
didn't tell you how now you already
could imagine some of the mechanisms it
could be insertion of those new
glutamate receptors those ampa receptors
that we talked about however even for
that to happen a bunch of other things
have to happen first but one of the key
ones to understand is the thing I
mentioned at the beginning of today's
episode bdnf which stands for brain
derived nootrophic Factor brain derived
nootrophic factor is an incredible
molecule I should mention that it's one
of many growth factors in the brain
and it has its own set of receptors it
binds to something called the track B
receptor trkb Trek B receptor when bdnf
binds to track B receptors on neurons it
does a lot of things it sets off a whole
Cascade of things including
the insertion of new glutamate receptors
so that those neurons become extra
sensitive to any input they get and so
that's one form of change that bdnf can
create bdnf can also alter the overall
shape of neurons it can cause neurons to
grow new branches so that it can receive
new inputs from other neurons anytime
bdnf is discussed in popular books or
the popular press people will talk about
it as quote unquote fertilizer for
neurons I don't really like that term
because it really undervalues the total
number of things that bdnf can do bdnf
actually can act as its own kind of
neurotransmitter it can actually
stimulate other neurons and it does a
bunch of other things but for sake of
this discussion about ketamine
understand that that burst firing of
neurons that very high frequency
firing of neurons can invoke the release
of bdnf in ways that make those circuits
very plastic very quickly and in
addition to that there's some evidence
that can I mean itself may be able to
cause release of bdnf directly without
having to go through all of the
mechanisms that I overwhelmed you with a
few minutes ago or hopefully didn't
overwhelm you with but that I talked to
you a few minutes ago now what's
especially exciting about bdnf in the
context of ketamine therapy for
depression is that it appears based on
both pre-clinical and clinical studies
that bdnf isn't just one of the ways in
which ketamine can invoke
neuroplasticity and these improvements
in mood it may actually be required it
may be the central process to all of
that now it can still be Downstream of
all that nmda receptor stuff that we
talked about before but there are
several lines of evidence that suggest
that ketamine-induced release of bdnf is
one of the core mechanisms by which
ketamine can relieve depression now
there are several lines of evidence to
support what I just said about bdnf in
the context of ketamine first of all
in mice that lack bdnf they have no bdnf
they can't make bdnf because they don't
have the gene for bdnf we call those
bdnf knockout mice in those mice if you
give them ketamine and you put them into
that learned helplessness task that we
talked about a bit earlier where you put
them into water and see how long they
swim normally ketamine would allow a
mouse to swim longer to fight for its
life longer well it no longer does that
in a bdnf knockout Mouse and the only
thing that's different about that Mouse
as far as we know is the lack of bdnf
and there are ways to make sure that
it's lack of bdnf in the specific
neurons that are relevant to everything
we're talking about not just that their
limbs don't work as well Etc in other
words all the appropriate control
experiments have been done that's
pre-clinical data because it comes from
animal models in addition to that
depressed people who have a mutant form
of bdnf so these humans are not
Knockouts for bdnf they can make bdnf
but the bdnf doesn't function normally
in those people
they have a very reduced response to
ketamine treatment for depression
suggesting that bdnf action is at least
one of the critical functions that
allows ketamine to relieve depression
and as I mentioned earlier ketamine can
actually invoke the release of bdnf and
get this there's some evidence that
ketamine itself can bind to the track B
receptor that is it can bind to the bdnf
receptor it can mimic bdnf
so this is an entirely different way of
thinking about ketamine than we normally
hear about nowadays we hear a lot about
ketamine and ketamine therapy we also
hear fortunately about some of the
problems of ketamine abuse and we will
talk about some of those concerns a
little bit later
and we hear about bdnf this so-called
brain fertilizer but rarely if ever do
we hear that ketamine itself can mimic
the effects of bdnf in the brain but
researchers and clinicians are
definitely paying attention to this and
it's starting to raise what I consider a
very exciting model of how ketamine
could provide relief for depression
which is that it's acting as a growth
factor in the brain or at least it's
mimicking the action of growth factors
allowing the specific neural circuits
that control things like mood outlook on
the future self-reflection Etc allowing
those circuits to change in ways that
provide significant relief for major
depression and in doing so and this is a
very important point it appears that
ketamine is relieving depression in ways
that are entirely different from any
other kind of treatment now in an
earlier episode about psilocybin and its
potential role for the treatment of
depression I went into a lot of depth
about how psilocybin can induce
neuroplasticity to provide relief for
major depression in certain individuals
under certain conditions I do want to
highlight that because indeed it's
another case where neuroplasticity is
involved but in that situation as some
of you may remember or if you don't
don't worry I'll tell you right now it
was a pretty straightforward model
psilocybin looks a lot like serotonin
chemically except that psilocybin binds
a particular receptor when that receptor
is bound it allows these brainwide
changes those brain wide changes seem to
change one's reflection on oneself
so-called ego dissolution changes and
mood that are stable over time
etc etc it was all pretty
straightforward with ketamine it's clear
there are multiple mechanisms involved
and perhaps most importantly with
ketamine it's that immediate relief that
occurs day of or close to day of
treatment and in the days afterwards and
it's that long-term relief that very
likely is the consequence of nmda
receptor suppression burst activity in
neurons Within These mood related
circuits bdnf being released and
changing neural circuits strengthening
them in order to give elevated mood as a
consequence of that bursting activity
and ketamine mimicking bdnf in other
words ketamine acting more or less like
a growth factor in the brain in order to
make sure that whatever changes occur in
those neural circuits to elevate mood
are durable that they really are
reinforced and last over time I'd like
to just take a brief break and thank one
of our sponsors which is element element
is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means plenty of salt sodium
magnesium and potassium the so-called
electrolytes and no sugar
now salt magnesium and potassium are
critical to the function of all the
cells in your body in particular to the
function of your nerve cells also called
neurons and we now know that even slight
reductions in electrolyte concentrations
or dehydration of the body can lead to
deficits and cognitive and physical
performance element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of 1000
milligrams that's one gram of sodium 200
milligrams of potassium and 60
milligrams of magnesium I typically
drink element first thing in the morning
when I wake up in order to hydrate my
body and make sure I have enough
electrolytes and while I do any kind of
physical training and after physical
training as well especially if I've been
sweating a lot and certainly I drink
element in my water when I'm in the
sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's
lmnt.com huberman to claim a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drink element lmnt.com
huberman so basically I've discussed two
major mechanism for how ketamine can
induce neuroplasticity leading to
improvements in mood and affect that
gives relief for depression
those two mechanisms are linked or at
the very least are happening in parallel
they're happening at the same time in
the brain now just to make matters more
interesting there's an incredible twist
into this whole thing of how ketamine
works and when I say how ketamine works
I'm not just talking about how ketamine
provides relief for depression I'm also
talking about why people use ketamine
for recreational purposes and it is the
following
yes ketamine has all these impacts on
excitatory neurons inhibitory neurons
bdnf etc etc but ketamine can also bind
receptors in the opioid pathway now what
is the opioid pathway don't worry here
I'm not going to hit you with a lot of
details but we've all heard of the
opioid crisis by now or at least most of
you have
the opioid crisis refers specifically to
people taking exogenous opioids taking
opioids right so taking pills that
activate particular receptors in the
brain that lead to
analgesia in some cases so pain relief
that lead to changes in mood there's a
lot to be said about the opioid crisis
it's called a crisis for a reason many
many people are addicted to those
compounds
that's a discussion for another time
keep in mind that The receptors those
drugs bind to are opioid receptors and
those receptors that you and I all have
by the way do not exist in order to bind
drugs that are made by pharmaceutical
companies they exist in our brain and
body to bind to the so-called endogenous
naturally made opioids that we all make
and those receptors have different names
the MU opioid receptor the Kappa opioid
receptor Etc they tend to have the names
of Greek letters to differentiate them
now ketamine can bind to various opioid
receptors and when opioid receptors are
bound we know that creates certain
effects things like pain relief things
like changes in psychic States
dissociation for example if enough of
them are bound you can get euphoric
States under certain conditions of
high-dose binding of ketamine to those
opioid receptors you can start getting
into planes of anesthesia where people
lose Consciousness and actually have no
response to pain whatsoever if you
recall the clinical studies we talked
about earlier where ketamine was used to
relieve depression
well the dosage used in that study as
you recall was half a milligram per
kilogram of body weight that is the
dosage that will induce these
dissociative mild euphoria
those sorts of states of mind but where
people are still conscious when you
start getting to dosages of ketamine
that are in the range of one to two
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
now you're talking about anesthetic
Doses and when that happens you're going
to get full parking full saturation of
all the potential receptors that
ketamine can bind to those nmda
receptors it's going to block those it's
also going to bind to the so-called mu
opioid receptors and maybe this other
type as well for those of you that want
to know you Aficionado is also the Kappa
type opioid receptors and so what we've
got here is a drug ketamine that is
hitting two different systems the
glutamate-related system
and the endogenous opioid system and
researchers and clinicians have
logically started to ask whether or not
some or all of the effects of ketamine
are due to the opioid system
and they want to know which effects
those are now this is where things start
to get really interesting both in the
context of clinical treatment of
depression and recreational use
first of all
when people take ketamine
again it enters the bloodstream and it
goes into the brain but it is
metabolized to something called hnk
which is hydroxy nor ketamine now I
don't expect you to know what hydroxy
nor ketamine is and I don't expect you
to care about it until I tell you what
I'm about to tell you which is that
hydroxy nor ketamine has an incredible
specificity for the MU opioid receptor
and maybe that Kappa opioid receptor as
well in other words when we talk about
ketamine that's the drug people take but
when it goes into the body it's
converted into yet another drug and that
other drug hydroxine or ketamine is
selectively activating the opioid system
so this led researchers to ask at a very
important question which is when a human
being takes ketamine in order to treat
their depression
and they get some relief from depression
is that the consequence of neuroplastic
changes in all those nmda glutamate bdnf
related circuits that we talked about
before or is it the consequence of
something happening in the opioid system
okay you can't ignore the fact that
ketamine has this property of binding to
these opioid receptors because they have
such a powerful effect on our thinking
on our mood on our state of
consciousness
it's entirely reasonable that the opioid
system could be a major player if not
the major player in this whole
depression relief thing and maybe even
in the creation of dissociative
symptomology when people take ketamine
recreationally so what researchers slash
clinicians did is they undertook a
series of experiments where they gave
people ketamine for the relief of
depression but they also blocked the
opioid receptor system and they did that
using a drug called Naltrexone so what
I'm about to describe to you is a study
done by my colleagues at Stanford School
of Medicine namely Dr Nolan Williams and
Alan schatzberg and colleagues entitled
attenuation of antidepressant and
anti-suicidal effects of ketamine by
opioid receptor antagonism and as a
consequence of me reading you that title
a moment ago you now already have the
conclusion of the study what they
observed is that when people were given
ketamine they got relief from depression
that wasn't surprising again many
studies had shown that before since the
early 2000s
if however individuals were given
Naltrexone to block the opioid receptor
pathway
and they were given ketamine well then
the antidepressant effects of ketamine
were no longer observed now that
suggests that it is the opioid receptor
system that's responsible for the
antidepressant effects of ketamine and
perhaps this hnk this hydroxy nor
ketamine which is the metabolite of
ketamine is the way in which ketamine
normally relieves depression
now a lot of people took note of these
studies because after all there are
probably dozens if not hundreds of
studies looking at the effects of
ketamine on all that nmda receptor stuff
and indeed neuroplasticity and mood
related circuits can't be discounted as
one way in which ketamine provides
relief from depression
but what was very interesting is that in
people given ketamine and Naltrexone
those people still experienced the
immediate effects of ketamine the mild
Euphoria the dissociation the feelings
that one would normally expect when
people were under the effects of
ketamine but what they didn't get were
the longer term changes in mood that we
would call relief from depression now of
course the goal of modern Psychiatry is
to treat depression not to block the
effects of these drugs that are capable
of treating depression now what this
study does and by the way there are
several studies like it that support
these General set of findings that part
of the critical role of ketamine in
providing relief from depression is to
activate the opioid system but what this
study does is it really points to the
fact that when we say ketamine treatment
or we talk about somebody taking
ketamine recreationally for that matter
we have to pay attention to what's
happening while they are under the
influence of the drug
we also have to pay attention to what's
happening in the days and weeks after
they're under the influence of the drug
and perhaps most importantly this calls
to mind a really important idea which is
that whether or not you're talking about
ketamine-induced relief from depression
or psilocybin induced relief for
depression or MDMA induced relief for
PTSD a topic that I covered on a
previous episode of this podcast
we have to step back and look at the
idea that the effects of the drug that
people experience whatever those may be
because obviously it's going to depend
on what particular drug they took
those immediate effects may not actually
be related to the long-term clinical
benefit of those particular drugs now I
realize that many people might not like
that idea and frankly I don't actually
think that's the way that it works I
don't think it's going to be an either
or situation however because drugs like
ketamine psilocybin MDMA have such
profound effects on people's psychic
States when they are under the influence
of them and because at least in the
proper clinical setting and use they do
seem to provide impressive relief from a
lot of these psychiatric challenges like
depression and PTSD
people naturally correlate those two
things they couple those two things in
fact they collapse those two things and
presume that their experience of what
they saw what they heard how they felt
while they were under the influence of
the drug was actually the stimulus that
created the relief from their clinical
condition like depression but what these
data on combined treatment with ketamine
and Naltrexone to block the MU opioid
receptor really show us is that that may
not actually be the way that it works it
may be that the effects of a drug like
ketamine that one experiences while
interesting perhaps even profound
perhaps great Insight comes to one when
they do that therapy in the proper
context
it is not clear at all that it is that
experience and the effects of those
drugs in those immediate minutes and
hours that's actually what's causing the
relief from depression now again I don't
think it's an either or I like to view
the whole situation more or less as a
sort of wave front that the experience
that one has subjectively while they are
under the influence of a drug like
ketamine or psilocybin or MDMA sets off
a series and in fact multiple series is
that a word multiple types of processes
in the brain some of which rely on
things like nmda receptor bdnf Etc type
neuroplasticity others which rely on the
opioid receptor pathway and that each of
these have different time courses such
that some provide immediate relief in
the days and hours after treatment some
in the weeks after treatment and some
more durable long-lasting changes that
can occur over months or maybe even
years and a really important thing to
underscore in the context of of all this
is that throughout today's discussion
we've been talking about drugs and
receptors and relief from depression but
what we're really talking about here are
people who get relief from depression
and almost with certainty when they get
relief from depression they are also
starting to do other things they are
going back to work they are engaging in
relationships again they are viewing
themselves differently again hopefully
they're getting morning sunlight and
exercising and eating well and doing all
the sorts of things that we would call
anti-depressive behaviors and it is
impossible to separate the positive
behavioral consequences of a drug
treatment for depression from the drug
itself in a way that lets us say Okay
ketamine relieved depression and then as
a consequence people went and did a
bunch of behaviors that were healthy for
them or stopped engaging in behaviors
that were unhealthy for them so we can
think of behaviors as pro-depressive or
antidepressive in fact we know that one
particular behavior that is viewing blue
light in the middle of the night between
the hours of say 11 pm and 4 AM is known
to invoke a pro-dopressive circuit it
involves a structure called the habenula
I've talked about this on previous
podcasts it tends to lower dopamine and
increase cortisol and the day is
following that exposure to light
Etc et cetera so there are
pro-depressive behaviors and there are
anti-depressive behaviors we know that
viewing morning sunlight getting regular
and sufficient amounts of quality sleep
proper nutrition proper social
engagement there is now a plethora of
quality research pointing to the fact
that those are true anti-depressive
behaviors so we can never separate out
the effects of a drug from the effects
of a drug that feed back on and combine
with the effects of the drug that one is
hoping for in this case depression
relief okay so I've been bookending this
conversation about ketamine at two very
Divergent levels meaning we've been
talking about high level stuff relief
from depressive symptoms right we
haven't been going into a lot of detail
about that but that's pretty high level
we're talking about thought changes
behavioral changes that we're calling
anti-depressive right changes in mood
and affect that are positive positive
anticipation of the future etc etc and
then we've also been talking a lot at
this other end which is very
reductionist down at the seller
molecular level we're talking about
receptors and binding of receptors and
neuroplasticity and track B and all that
stuff we've completely neglected meaning
I've completely neglected until now
what Bridges those two levels of
understanding and what Bridges those two
levels of understanding are the neural
circuits that actually change when one
takes ketamine whether or not those
changes occur quickly whether or not
they take a longer period of time
whether or not they involve an MDA
receptors or the opioid receptor systems
or both
we know that certain neural circuits
change when people take ketamine in
these patterns of dosage and frequency
of about half a milligram per kilogram
and again that's the injected form twice
per week over three weeks and then they
get some durable resistance to
depression fortunately we can talk about
those neural circuits without having to
bring about a lot more nomenclature a
lot of new language and I say
fortunately because I realize today
you've been hit with a lot of new terms
now I've already mentioned one of the
key brain structures and that's the
habenula a few moments ago I talked
about the habenula in the context of
people who get too much bright the light
exposure in the middle of the night that
activates the habenula it's a sort of a
disappointment circuit we can call it
that because we know that it leads to
pro-dopressive symptoms in animal models
and very likely in humans as well and it
does so we know by reducing dopamine and
increasing cortisol there is evidence
that when people undergo ketamine
therapy connections between the habenula
what we can broadly just talk about is a
structure involved in gen generating a
feeling of disappointment
the connections between the habenula and
the reward circuitry of the brain which
I've talked about several times before
on this podcast but for those of you
that aren't familiar with it this is the
so-called mesolimbic reward pathway it
has areas like the ventral tegmental
area the nucleus accumbens don't worry
at all about those names just know that
this is a brain area that is
chock-a-block full of neurons that
release dopamine which is a molecule
that tends to increase mood increase
motivation in many ways we can think
about it at least for sake of this
discussion as anti-depressive so what
we've got is a structure the habenula
that normally provides inhibitory and
now you know what that means inhibitory
input to this reward pathway that
releases dopamine and when people take
ketamine that inhibition is lessened
such that the reward pathway is more
available for engagement through daily
life activities now I say available for
engagement through daily life activities
for a very specific purpose which is
that all the changes in neural circuits
that we're talking about that can come
about from taking a drug well those
changes don't actually do a whole lot
unless those circuits are reinforced by
particular behaviors so this relates
back to what I said just a few minutes
ago about
pro-depressive and anti-depressive
behaviors somebody can take ketamine and
potentially get relief from depression
but if they continue to engage in
pro-dopressive behaviors
they are not going to get much of any
relief from depression conversely if
somebody takes ketamine and they are
reducing the amount of output from this
disappointment circuit this habenula to
the reward circuitry of the brain and
they do engage in behaviors such as
seeking out work that stimulates them
seeking out social engagement taking
good care of their body their mental
health their physical health Etc well
those circuits are not designed to
respond to ketamine they are designed to
respond to particular patterns of
thinking and behavior so again we can't
forget that when we hear that a drug
causes plasticity in a given neural
circuit what it's doing is it's biasing
the balance or the probability that
those neural circuits will be engaged by
certain activities but one still has to
engage in those activities now
fortunately when people tend to have
elevations in mood they tend to move
around more when they tend to move
around more they tend to engage in more
things when they tend to engage in more
things if they have a positive outlook
on life presumably they are engaging in
adaptive things things like social
relationships job related School related
goal-related Behavior so it's important
to understand that a discussion of
neural circuit changes in response to
ketamine is really a discussion of
ketamine that shift one's overall system
toward having yet further neural circuit
changes in response to daily activities
and thereby bolstering health or in this
case mental health now it's also
important to understand that rarely if
ever does a drug provide relief for some
sort of clinical challenge in just a
one-track kind of way the way to think
about this is that most mental processes
and certainly things like depression are
a two-way Road you have pro-dopressive
behaviors in circuits and you have
anti-depressive behaviors in circuits
and so perhaps it won't be surprising to
you that there's evidence that ketamine
treatment can reduce the output from the
habenula to the reward pathway this
disappointment to reward pathway
weakening that making the reward pathway
more available for engagement through
thoughts and behaviors that are anti
depressive and in addition to that it
can further bolster the neuroplasticity
within the reward pathway itself in
particular with connections with the
frontal cortex and for those of you that
aren't familiar with the frontal cortex
your frontal cortex does a lot of things
but one of the things that your frontal
cortex is absolutely critical for is for
establishing
context-dependent strategy meaning for
allowing you to say okay in a given
circumstance what should I do to get the
results I want in another circumstance
what should I do to get the results I
want it's not strategizing of the
manipulative type although I suppose it
could be it's strategizing of how do I
get what I need from this social
connection how do I get what I need from
my goals and exercise how do I get what
I need from my goals in terms of work or
school Etc your frontal cortex is that
part of your cortex that's always
churning ideas it's always wondering am
I doing well am I not doing well and is
adjusting your behavior accordingly so
it's now established that ketamine can
improve connectivity that is it can
strengthen the connections between areas
of the brain that are associated with
context-dependent strategy building and
these reward Pathways in other words it
makes people more sensitive to whether
or not they are getting the results they
want from their efforts and to how to
adjust their efforts so that they do get
the results they want from those efforts
and there's other evidence that nmda
receptor blockade is not the way that
ketamine provides relief from depression
namely there's a drug called mementine
it's used actually to treat Alzheimer's
and it too is an nmda receptor blocker
and it has no antidepressant effects now
as you recall ketamine is a dissociative
anesthetic and one of its primary
effects is to create this feeling of
dissociation for those those of you that
aren't familiar with what dissociation
is dissociation is where people feel
separate from their body they can still
think but it's as if they are observing
themselves in fact in anticipation for
this episode I consulted with several
different colleagues in the department
of Psychiatry at Stanford school of
medicine and one of them described the
effects of ketamine as described by a
patient of theirs who had taken ketamine
for the treatment of depression
and that patient described it as
observing themselves thinking observing
themselves doing things even though they
were lying completely still and perhaps
most importantly describing themselves
as being above their body and actually
looking down on themselves from the
third person perspective now that I
realize is a foreign experience to most
people but of course there are people
who experienced dissociation even while
not on ketamine and as many of you know
dissociation is actually one of the
primary symptoms of PTSD and Trauma so
this raises a sort of conundrum you know
why is it that a particular state of
mind that's associated with PTSD and
Trauma and in some cases depression
itself
which is induced by a drug like ketamine
can provide relief from depression and
that all goes back to the neuroplastic
changes that we talked about earlier and
more likely the changes in the MU opioid
receptor system that we talked about
earlier but nonetheless the dissociative
effects of ketamine are so profound for
people that take them that I thought I'd
spend a minute or two explaining what
likely causes that dissociative third
personing of self-effect and insofar as
we know it has to do with an uncoupling
of certain brain circuits in particular
neocortical brain circuits the neocortex
is the part of the brain the lumpy
outside part of the brain that's
associated with action planning it does
a lot of things really it's involved in
sensory perception it's involved in
speech generation many many things but
the neocortex has connections to other
regions which are called subcortical
regions and it seems that when people
take ketamine or phen cycladine PCP
there's an uncoupling of those networks
acquiring of those networks that starts
to create a different dominant rhythm in
the brain some of you may be familiar
with rhythms in the brain so-called
Alpha rhythms or Alpha patterns of
activity that's just dominant patterns
of activity associated with particular
brain States so for instance Alpha brain
waves are associated with an alert but
calm relaxed State of Mind where
thoughts are sort of free-flowing it's a
little bit dreamlike but it isn't really
like a dream where anything can happen
it has a structure to it when people
take ketamine the alpha pattern of
activity is completely abolished at
least for the duration of time that
they're under the influence of the drug
which typically is about an hour to two
hours or so and a different pattern of
brain activity which is called the Theta
pattern of brain activity starts to
really emerge it's as if it gets
unveiled and that Theta pattern of
activity is the one that's associated
with a dream-like state it's the one
that resides more or less at that
liminal border between wakefulness and
sleep if you've ever been falling asleep
and you were thinking something like you
were running and you kicked your leg
it's very likely that you were in a
Theta pattern of activity in your brain
at that moment
just prior to when you woke up whereas
when you're more alert you see patterns
of activity that are higher frequency
things like Alpha Beta rhythms and so
forth so ketamine produces particular
patterns of brain activity and this
sense of dissociation when it's taken at
sub anesthetic doses if you recall the
clinical studies we talked about earlier
they injected half a milligram per
kilogram of body weight in order to
provide depression relief for those
patients when people take ketamine they
will take it by different routes of
delivery and now here we have to expand
our conversation to include both the
clinical context research studies and
recreational use
now I do that because typically when
people take ketamine in a study in a
clinical study they will get an
intravenous into the vein or an
intramuscular into the muscle injection
of half a milligram per kilogram of body
weight ketamine however when people are
taking ketamine recreationally or when
they are accessing ketamine legally by
prescription and taking it at home which
is becoming a more common practice they
will often take it orally in pill form
or they will take it sublingually by
putting it under the tongue or in their
cheek and then that so-called troche
dissolves and the ketamine goes into
their system now an important thing to
understand is that when people take
ketamine orally only 25 percent of the
active form of ketamine makes it into
the bloodstream and when they take it
sublingually typically only about 35
percent of the total amount of ketamine
they take is converted into
metabolically active ketamine that acts
on the neurons in their brain so when
you hear about the dosages used in
studies they are going to generally
involve injections of ketamine and far
lower doses of ketamine than when you
hear about people taking ketamine orally
or sublingually so for instance I weigh
220 pounds that's 100 kilograms so if I
were to be in one of these studies which
I have not been but if I were
I would be given 50 milligrams of
ketamine by way of injection however if
I were going to try to achieve the same
amount of active ketamine in my
bloodstream and brain as I would through
injection I would need to ingest three
times as much ketamine by way of pill
and perhaps a little bit more by way of
sublingual ketamine if I wanted to get
the same effects so if I were to take 50
milligrams by way of injection in a
study and I went to a different study
and they said okay we want to recreate
that effect we're going to give you a
pill typically they're going to give me
150 milligrams of ketamine in a pill
form or 200 milligrams of ketamine in
the troche sublingual form now it's
really important to understand this dose
dependence according to delivery
business because I realize that nowadays
especially a lot of people are taking
ketamine through legal sources so
they're accessing it legally but they're
taking it outside the clinic and more
typically they're taking it not by way
of injection meaning they're taking
higher dose ketamine and they're taking
it sublingually or orally so it's very
important to understand this dose
dependence according to mode of delivery
business now in anticipation of this
episode I put out a request for
questions about ketamine on Twitter and
I got many many questions some X
excellent ones they're in but one of the
more common questions was what is a
k-hole in scientific terms a k-hole is
what's used to describe the subjective
experience of when somebody takes
ketamine typically recreationally and
they end up in basically a
pseudo-anesthetized state
what that means is that they took a
dosage that for them put them beyond the
boundary of the sub anesthetic dose and
has them transitioning into the
anesthesia level dose of ketamine
now I mentioned everything I did about
dosages before because it's very
important to know that different people
even if they are of equivalent body
weight are going to respond to ketamine
differently depending on how quickly and
how thoroughly they metabolize ketamine
so
in the clinical context injections of
ketamine into the vein or into the
muscle are done at this half a milligram
per kilogram dose and they have
clinicians there they have researchers
there who are paying attention to
whether or not the person is in a
associative state if they're still
conscious and to see whether or not the
person is going into full-blown
anesthesia now that's one of the values
of doing ketamine in the context of a
legal clinical setting however I'd be
remiss if I didn't acknowledge that a
lot of people are getting ketamine
legally but then taking it at home
hopefully not alone hopefully there's
someone there to monitor them where
they're in session with their physician
over Zoom that's actually happening more
and more these days through Telehealth
but that itself also has certain risks
right because if the person needs
something and they don't have someone
there immediately in the room to take
care of it that could be a very
problematic situation and of course
there are situations where people are
taking ketamine recreationally
regardless of how they're acquiring it
they're taking it and they are guessing
how they are going to respond to it
based on some crude understanding of
dosages but when people talk about a
k-hole what they're talking about is
taking ketamine at a dose that for them
takes them beyond the mild or perhaps
even an extreme dissociation
and starts placing them into full-blown
anesthesia and that itself actually can
be dangerous
going into anesthesia like planes of
Consciousness while not always deadly
can be deadly and it certainly can be
and has been deadly when people start to
combine it with other drugs in
particular drugs like barbiturates or
alcohol so I want to be very clear that
the dosage ranges that you hear about
when hearing about ketamine are
extremely Broad and so is the
variability to any one given dose and so
too is the response to a given dose in a
given person depending on the route of
delivery you need to be very careful
about the ability of ketamine to take
you into deep deep planes of
unconsciousness and in some cases death
and of course as with any sedative one
needs to be extremely cautious about
doing anything like driving or even
walking in traffic or walking anywhere
in some cases if one is under the
influence of ketamine additionally for
those of you that are seizure prone
either due to epilepsy or prior head
injury or maybe your seizure pronoun you
don't know it can mean can induce
seizures and it should be completely
obvious to you now why that's the case
ketamine blocks nmda receptors on
inhibitory neurons and quiets their
activity which of course can lead to
Runaway excitation in the brain if you
are seizure prone when I put out the
request for questions about ketamine on
social media I also got a lot of
questions about the different forms of
ketamine when I say different forms that
included questions about whether or not
intranasal was better than oral was
better than sublingual etc etc
to be fair with one exception the
different modes of delivery probably
relate more to dosage that actually gets
metabolized than to anything else what I
mean by that is most people don't know
how to equate the clinical dose of half
a milligram per kilogram of body weight
into a dosage to take orally or
sublingually or in some cases by the way
people will take it rectally and the
reason people take ketamine rectally is
that rectal Administration bypasses the
liver and indeed ketamine can be hard on
the liver to metabolize it can
dramatically increase liver enzymes so
oftentimes people that are taking
ketamine frequently and don't want to
create damage to the liver they will opt
for a rectal Administration now I
realize that unless it's somehow related
to your profession anytime somebody says
intraectally it raises a few eyebrows
and people you know kind of lean back a
little bit and I get it in a future
episode of the podcast I promise to
distinguish between the different modes
of drug metabolism depending on whether
or not people take something orally
sublingually by injection or rectally
another common question I got when I
solicited for questions about ketamine
on social media was about the R versus S
versus RS forms of ketamine and I must
tell you that sent me down a deep deep
Rabbit Hole of research in which I
discovered very contradictory evidence
for instance I could find papers I did
find papers that said that the r form of
ketamine had a much greater affinity for
the nmda receptor than did the S form of
ketamine I also found reviews that said
the exact opposite okay and there I was
sitting with the two reviews in front of
one another wondering if there was
something wrong with my visual system
until I called a colleague Dr Nolan
Williams who's a triple board certified
neurologist psychiatrist at Stanford
School of Medicine whose laboratory
specializes in the use of ketamine for
studies of treating depression and for
treating depression in the clinical
population so I asked him what's the
deal here I'm getting very contradictory
evidence and he spelled it all out for
me
it appears based on the clinical data in
humans and on binding studies that the S
form of ketamine is more potent that is
it can more robustly bind to the nmda
receptor and in addition to that the S
form of ketamine tends to produce less
dissociation at a given dosage than does
the combined Sr form of ketamine or pure
R ketamine
he also added and sent me a study that
I'll link in the show note captions that
there was recently a clinical trial of
r-ketamine so pure R ketamine alone
and it failed to relieve depressive
symptoms
so I said great thank you so much this
is now all made very clear to me that s
ketamine is the preferred form it
produces less dissociation and it
provides better depression relief and
then he said no actually it's a little
more complicated than that it appears
the situation is the following the
combined Sr form of ketamine seems to be
the most potent for relieving depressive
symptoms
the S form of ketamine
is second best in terms of providing
relief from depressive symptoms and is
the one that's most commonly prescribed
nowadays
by nasal spray by Oral dosing by
sublingual dosing and it's what is
typically given by way of injection in
clinical studies where they do
injections
and it appears that the r form of
ketamine is the least potent and
effective in treating depression now I
realize that by putting this out into
the larger world and assuming that there
are experts in ketamine out there either
by way of use or by clinical study of
their own that I will get a lot of
comments back saying no actually the r
form was more effective for me than the
S form versus the SR form Etc just to
reiterate from the clinical trials that
have been done we know that the combined
Sr form is more potent and effective
than the pure s form which is still more
effective than the pure R form so that's
what we know now based on the clinical
studies but of course I acknowledge that
anytime a drug is out there as a
clinical tool and it's being used
recreationally that people are going to
explore and they're going to experiment
and they're going to find what works
best for them so I certainly invite
feedback about what has worked best for
you hopefully in the clinical context so
whether or not people have used ketamine
prescription from their doctor whether
or not they participated in a clinical
study or whether or not they're doing it
recreationally I imagine that I will
hear about those experiences and I will
take note of them another commonly asked
question I received was what about
microdosing of ketamine there's a lot of
interest in microdosing nowadays people
are micro dosing psilocybin people are
micro dosing all sorts of things hoping
to get some of the same effects as the
macro doses but by using dosages of
compounds that are below what would
induce say in the case of psilocybin
hallucinations or in the case of
ketamine below what would induce the
kind of dissociation and euphoric
effects that one would have to lie down
for a few hours and disengage for the
rest of the day I consulted with my
clinician colleagues about this and they
told me that at present meaning as of
yesterday there is zero published
clinical evidence that they are aware of
and by way of extension that I am aware
of in which microdosing ketamine has
been effective for the treatment of
depression all of the positive effects
on depression that I've talked about
during this episode are gleaned from
studies where people used this half
milligram per kilogram dosage of
ketamine or its equivalent by way of
some other route of administration not
injected but oral or sublingual so are
there any benefits to microdose and
ketamine as far as the scientific and
clinical literature that's published as
of today is concerned the answer is no
okay so today we covered a lot of
information we talked about what
ketamine is remember ketamine and PCP
angel dust very similar compounds both
block the nmda receptor we also talked
about what sorts of subjective effects
that produces dissociation and Mild
Euphoria and third personing of self
that's the dissociation when taken at
low dosages and when taken at higher
dosages it can induce full-blown
anesthesia and put people into
subconscious States and there's actually
a potential even for seizure and death
if the dosage is high enough for that
person again I want to emphasize that
people's dosage sensitivity varies
tremendously route of delivery will
impact that and on and on we also talked
about how the nmda receptor itself
and the activation of this incredible
molecule bdnf brain derived nootrophic
Factor seemed to be important for at
least some of the antidepressant effects
of ketamine both in the days and weeks
following ketamine Administration and in
addition to that I described how
ketamine impacts the opioid receptor
system and how we simply cannot Overlook
the involvement of the opioid receptor
system in producing the antidepressant
effects of ketamine and we also talked
about the brain circuits and the brain
waves associated with dissociative
States and the depression relief that
seems to arrive for many people who take
ketamine and I tried to highlight some
of the unique features of ketamine first
of all that it does seem to provide
depression relief where other approaches
have not but that the depression relief
tends to be pretty short-lived unless
it's applied in this multi-times per
week over multiple weeks kind of fashion
to produce what I call durable changes
which almost certainly involve changes
in neuroplasticity that is rewiring of
brain circuits and another key point
that I highlighted is is that we always
have to remember that when thinking
about how chemicals like ketamine or any
other substance for that matter can
modify brain circuits in order to change
them and provide relief from depression
or some other psychiatric challenge that
always always always there is a
requirement for engaging in
anti-depressive behaviors as a way to
further reinforce whatever positive
changes have come about through the drug
treatment as a friend and colleague of
mine who's expert in this area once so
aptly said Better Living Through
Chemistry still requires Better Living
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion about ketamine if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zero cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five star
review if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or guests
that you'd like me to consider hosting
on the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not on today's podcast but on
any previous episodes of The huberman
Lab podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like sleep
support hormone support and improving
Focus the huberman Lab podcast has
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to learn more about the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentous
spelled ous so it's livemomentis.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am hubermanlab on
all platforms so Instagram Twitter
threads Facebook and Linkedin and on all
of those platforms I cover science and
science-based tools some of which
overlap with the content of the huberman
Lab podcast but much of which is
distinct from the content of the uberman
Lab podcast so again it's huberman lab
on all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to our neural
network newsletter our neural network
newsletter is a free monthly newsletter
that includes podcast summaries and
protocols in the form of brief one to
three page PDFs those protocols include
things like a tool kit to enhance the
quality and duration of your sleep
toolkits to improve learning and
neuroplasticity toolkits for deliberate
cold exposure exercise Focus dopamine
and on and on to sign up for the neural
network newsletter you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter you sign up using
your email but I want to emphasize that
we do not share your email with anybody
thank you once again for joining me for
today's discussion and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]